welcome em Western em Western let's see
I really have printed 15 times will have
no particular recollection about the
games and probably had this stuff
earlier yeah we did a really dead it's a
very weird water with castles first okay
Queen f5 it's how they usually play it
okay
yeah I thought just III but I can't
think about I can do that it's not a bad
idea i believe I mean he's very crowded
on the diagonal
yeah I can make a move the queen of
course a question is where b3 is maybe
Bishop t5 now then have c4 let's do that
really wonder if that it is any good all
those cream mousse okay it still seems
fairly solid in this position so c5
coming here maybe this one 4c 556 that
should win a porn of course it's played
anyway maybe it doesn't matter yeah it's
made me right Bishop t6 rookie 8d take C
594 might might do the trick
I can take with the bishop actually
Bishop takes be takes Queen B 7 okay
it's not the greatest point to win
anyway but o our city stuff you are
silly stuff okay
now I have choir I just I just didn't
see that who been a long playing session
here okay it's not over yet but okay I
have to be active there I know I'm
dropping the tool but I don't care
activity calcium so you may be very bad
Ok Go queen bee 7 he will take a Jew at
the end that's not grade so let's try to
push the rook back first and then go
queen bee cell I shouldn't forget that
two nights he cannot check mate if it
sounds weird but it's really a factor
here in many situations so I might be
able to escape due to that little fact
it's 94 okay 94 Luke c7 if I get rook
against I mean if I just can trade all
the pawns the drawing chances are still
there
I don't know is that really a way for
him to play for a window or I don't wait
wait wait wait on it just a moment there
should never really forget about maybe
winning the game a 585 I will see
playing after that if I go a 591 a b6
let's do it i don't see how he saves
himself but i'm probably miscalculating
as I did earlier on but i can probably
you can save himself in a couple of ways
but still he had have some ideas to win
maybe I think it can take tinky one
actually maybe 656 it should should
should be at least two drove him that
should be a draw i believe he has the
sea porn that should secure the draw but
there is no way for me to win right
probably yeah probably not not
objectively yeah might just win the sea
Paul time worrying
then i can try with the exchange up
let's see i don't have a clear idea how
to win here i have to admit pushing the
pawns forward is probably parted we
doesn't have many squares with the light
let's see if i can check cut him off
that's probably a good defense check
look age four and then King g6 check
black resigns yeah I should have never
won that game but um yeah was really
really bad player for me I'm very
curious if I could have done something
with that opening I really have my
doubts about black set up here maybe
there's really nothing great that I can
do I mean II lost implicit many Queen
moves to return back to the eighth but
the resulting position still feels very
solid so maybe I really have nothing
maybe we should be three years so i
don't know i mean this this was okay and
i'm hitting great stuff i was seeing
this of course and ever okay 94 hmm kind
of annoying so i went Bishop c5 yeah
yeah it wasn't working at all yeah here
on 81 i can sleep with that and I'm okay
because he cannot take now Dooley this
is not not possible yeah this is just
stupid stuff now i'm clearly worse and
really should should just lose now maybe
you just you should just keep the
Queen's on I think that would help a lot
actually but again here you should
really never lose the game
then I hear it starts to get get get
somewhat tricky and yeah I think I mean
the likelihood that I'm escaping to the
mentioned end game with rook yeah with
the see the rook against the two nights
and it's pretty likely actually what is
the engines top line this one this is
this this seems X moods actually it's
actually keeping it the computer keeps
the pawn the nights are somewhat tied
together no idea if that is a win for
black maybe the nights are not exactly
so active on the quarter corner yeah but
something like that he should be the one
trying and now after a five it's it's
it's it's very very tricky probably
check the way we played it this is the
best line and now I pretty much win the
sea porn by force and yeah this should
be objectively I guess a win but I
didn't really approve it proven in the
game I mean I warned ultimately but
didn't feel very very convincing okay
thanks for watching